il faut replacer cette découverte dans
son contexte c'est un traitement qui ne
s'applique pas à tous les cas
d'infections commis le 19 mai aux cas
les plus les plus graves dans lesquels
il y à une atteinte de pulmonaire qui
met en danger la vie du patient et on
voit que effectivement ce sont les
patients qui sont placés sous
ventilation artificielle et qui
bénéficie le plus de l'efficacité de ce
traitement par la dexaméthasone puisque
c'est dans ce groupe de patients que
l'on observe une réduction de la
mortalité de 30 % dans que c'est un
traitement qui sait bien que c'était
cette étude et était fait et puis
qu'elle puisse quantifier le bénéfice
apporté par ce traitement
pour quel type de patients mais il faut
savoir que beaucoup de nos hôpitaux ont
appliqué ce traitement déjà depuis le
début de l'épidémie avec sans doute des
dons autant de succès mais bien sûr ce
n'était pas un introduit dans le cadre
d'un essai clinique et c'est tout le
taux davantage que qu'apporte cette
étude recovery qui nous donne un des
valeurs chiffrées qui permet donc de
faire une avancée significative dans la
prise en charge des formes graves de la
cofidis 9